denise it really is college football
programs are starting to scramble amid
the latest spikes in covet in the last
four weeks
about 70 games have been postponed or
canceled that's about 30 percent of the
250 games that were scheduled
you look at the games just today unlv's
home game against boise state
was canceled over health concerns in
nevada that's not the only one affected
just today uab that game was canceled
they haven't played a game in a month
houston has had seven games canceled
michigan
had its game with maryland canceled just
today so many games affected by the
virus
miami of ohio had its game canceled
just today going back to the rebels now
that game against boise state that was
their last home game of the season
they've got a trip to hawaii plan for
december 12th
odds telling us that game probably will
be cancelled as well
as for the las vegas bowl it was
cancelled today so that plan of having
the pac-12 facing the sec
at allegiant stadium that'll have to
wait until next december
other bowl games are likely to follow
suit soon
brian